yes Fritzi we have mr. Brian McKnight on
the line from Los Angeles cowboy fan and
singer-songwriter whoa Brian good
morning how are you how are you I'm good
now I heard you're a cowboy fan are you
are you calling in just cuz morale is
high and you want to talk about your
Cowboys well of course because everybody
said we were so dead in the water
five weeks ago six weeks ago however
when we got Amari Cooper okay and I told
everybody at the time that that wasn't
the one of the one things we needed to
get Zeke freed up to take one of those
guys out of the box that we could get
some running and then Zach will show
that he was exactly what he was two
years ago and guess what
as usual I'm right would you let it
rather win a Grammy or have the Cowboys
make the Superbowl Cowboys make the
Superbowl
what if Cowboys make the Superbowl and
lose or you can have a Grammy Awards are
nice again my brother's got ten of them
and that's a great thing but to me you
know selling records and selling concert
tickets to me our bigger deal than the
Grammys Grammys are great it's great to
have one I'm not gonna turn one down if
they give me one but I think I'll just
continue doing what I'm doing and hoping
they're the Cowboys win dot if the
Cowboys lose okay when did you fall in
love with the Cowboys I played running
back when I was in Little League and
Tony Dorsett was my favorite player he
won the Heisman 76 I believe and he got
drafted to the Cowboys I became a cowboy
fan when I was eight years old didn't
you grow up in Buffalo I did I know I
owed a Simpsons kid as well but
something about 22 over said just that I
don't know just one of those things and
I was never a Buffalo Bills I think I
think I was to Orchard Park once my
father except me and my brothers there
those to see a game it was so cold you
know that's it that's it for me have you
sung the anthem for the Cowboys
once on Thanksgiving in the old stadium
and two or three times after that as
well
have you met most of the Roger Staubach
and Aikman and Michael Irvin you know
all those guys really really cool with
them talking about Cowboys players and
even Jerry and then once the Cowboys on
you in the family
once they know you're a real cowboy fan
and I am a real Cowboys fan you ever
written a song about the Cowboys no
haven't gone quite that far I'm not in
love with the Cowboys Dan I just love
you but you're known for your love songs
that's why that's what the line kind of
stops but yeah well maybe you know an
idea in my studio right now so maybe out
what do you have in there in front of
you you got your piano you got well you
play you like every instrument not every
instrument that there's last things I
play like nine but there's way more
sense tonight can you do Rick James
super freak right now for us how about
super Zeke about super Zeke as Rick
James super Zeki you got to work on the
lyrics we got the melody there
he's an all-purpose back you know we
could come up with that we you know what
we could probably do that together next
time I'm there and you will write a song
about the Cowboys the next time I have
you in studio because he's an
all-purpose back he pairs well with dak
we're halfway there I just need a chorus
there yeah I need a course they were
super Zekey yeah that sounds good
are you out on that I know you just got
back you were out of the country are you
on tour I have my last number 153 Oh
Marksville Louisiana wait you've had
another 53 shows that'll be number 152 I
was in the Asia for two weeks last week
I had to show three so actually four
shows don't you know two shows in the
Philippines and then number 51 53 this
weekend in Louisiana you work with a lot
of people if I said you could do one
more visit than work with somebody you
work with Timberlake mary j blige mace
nelly P Diddy
who would you want to go back and do
something again out of that group Justin
you know I think we had some magic in
the studio on this first album I think
that was one of the best albums he's
ever done super talent again and far
more talented can people really know or
cuz he doesn't really get to show it and
then I was like records you can really
show us a man he deserves everything
he's ever gotten just great and proud
that we were having a discussion the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame inductees
just came out and I'm wondering as we
look at music you know looking at record
sales like how would you define what is
greatness like the impact cultural
impact you know Taylor Swift's gonna
sell more records than Prince but Prince
is one of those talented musicians of
all time like I'm not sure how we
differentiate greatness in the music
world now I think it's generational
honestly Taylor Swift for her generation
is their prince and that sounds crazy
but it isn't how talented you are
necessarily to the consumer yeah I think
it is how how your fans make you feel
and I think the true test is really
longevity beyond that because if you can
transcend your generation to the next
generation to the next Arace message
that's I think that's the one thing that
Prince may have over a Taylor Swift tune
a cellphone record in theory French Sir
Michael Jackson with a bigger impact
impact I would say Michael Jackson in
our heart
probably Prince why why in our hearts
because when you're the actual creator
of the musics as opposed to the guy who
sort of out front I think it's if
there's something about the fact that
it's his music his music alone he's the
only guy he's got it's playing
everything the guy just writing
everything I think that that resonates
with people and he has his own sound
you know I'm Michael get to my it's
apples and oranges really honestly I
think that for me to as musician I tend
to lean towards Chris I and and before I
let you go I got to call you out on this
I know you're big cowboy fan we're
talking to Brian McKnight
singer/songwriter you your favorite
basketball team used to be the Bulls
when Michael was there you're a Yankee
fan of Duke basketball
Tiger Woods Roger Federer Serena
Williams come on Brian you know you like
what you like and I think that I think
that's what being human is about it's
not it's not geographical it's not it's
what's in your heart it's called being a
front-runner Brian not at all because
again when I was a Bulls fans because I
saw Michael did adore theee Caroline and
nobody could have yes
not even by only Bobby Knight was the
only one that said he was gonna get
crazy stuff till he got on the NBA floor
and you say oh my god is the only guy
that can stop Michael Jordan's games
with this you know this yeah so it
wasn't like it was it was a given him
for seven years
there was heartbreak and in all of a
sudden Nadi got there and Horace and
Phil then they had something and then
they do you know the dynasty so look
like I jumped on an 89 all right work on
that cowboy song all right I got it
super Zekey thank you Brian Brian
McKnight cowboy apologist
singer-songwriter very very talented
musician
I think super Ziggy's got some legs
there it's an all-purpose back
pairs well with this quarterback or no
doc in a we can I think we can work them
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]